hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten mit
heute gibt's das zweite video zu meiner
neuen reihe und ihr habt mir ganz viele
namensvorschläge geschickt und es wie
wir wirklich schwert ist auszusuchen und
im passenden rahmen zu finden
ich habe jetzt zwei namensvorschläge
kombiniert und zwar nehme ich diese
reihe jetzt nachgemacht original trifft
sally und in dieser serie werde ich
originale einfach nachmachen und euch
eben die rezepte verraten
bei den nachgemachten sachen das ist
natürlich nicht immer die original
rezepte an die kuppel nicht ran aber ich
versuche immer so nah wie möglich ans
original zu kommen
beim letzten mal habe ich die milch
schritte gemacht da verlinke ich euch
gerne hier nochmal das video und heute
haben wir uns dazu entschlossen
entwickelt zu machen weil wir bauen
dieses erleben
und weil ich sowieso total jakobus keine
bringen
in den originalen bounty sticks einige
zutaten drin die ich nicht verwenden
möchte da ist zum beispiel sven
kakaobutter glukosesirup kakaomasse
loyalität milchzucker magermilchpulver
also lauter produkte thema zwar bekommt
und bestellen kann
aber die ich einfach nicht verwenden
möchte weil sie nicht an tätig sind
ich werde deswegen die zutaten etwas
austauschen und werde euch zeigen dass
ich benutze ihr braucht 280 gramm
kokosraspeln genau 100 gramm zucker 25
gramm vanillezucker oder einfach zwei
packungen der zucker wobei ich immer den
selbstgemachten neben 200 gramm
schlagsahne eine prise salz 125 g butter
und zu überziehen später 200 gramm
vollmilchschokolade
für die mounties braucht ihr nicht lange
und die bautiefe hätten auch gar nicht
gebacken sondern diese cocos maße wird
auf den herd gekocht
die bauten sind wirklich sehr schnell
zubereitet ihr müsst nur bedenken dass
ihr eine wartezeit von etwa fünf bis
sechs stunden habt also das ist
eigentlich das was am längsten dauert
das ist das was soll ich anfangen müssen
und ich zeige euch jetzt wie man dieser
masse herstellt jetzt nimmst du doch
butter und die kommt da rein
super die butter muss jetzt im topf
erhitzt werden
und bevor sie ganz geschmolzen ist geben
wir noch die sahne mit rein damit es
jetzt auch nicht verbrennt weil die
mutter allein würde ihr verbrennen
und jetzt müssen wir warten bis ein mal
aufgekocht es ist lustig nicht und wenn
es kocht darfst du jetzt salz und zucker
mit dazu geben
jetzt darf
vanillezucker genau normaler zucker und
salz und jetzt schön rühren
das mache ich ganz kurz
und es lassen wir jetzt so etwa 23
minuten kochen
bis sich der zucker komplett aufgelöst
hat genau und jetzt kommen die
kokosraspeln vorher muss man aufpassen
weil das mache ich jetzt dann kann man
den herd auch ausschalten und wenn es
komplett verrührt ist kann es vom herd
unternehmen
und wenn ihr diese mache dann gekocht
habt müssen was jetzt noch in so eine
schöne form schichten und ich nehme
jetzt dazu der ganz normale auflaufen
ihr könnt einfach irgendeine form nehmen
die ihr gerade habt meine hat jetzt die
maße etwa 16.30 und die werde ich jetzt
noch mit etwas folie auslegen und zwar
lege ich das einmal drüber und schnapp
schön damit auskleiden und auch schön am
rand und achtet darauf dass es hier so
flach wie möglich anlegt und jetzt
nehmen wir diese masse und füllt sie
schön hier rein und dann hinter einfach
gefunden hast so dass die masse etwa
zwei bis drei zentimeter hoch drin steht
und erst mal schön verteilen geld mäßig
jetzt noch flach gedrückt werden das
können wir mit den händen machen aber
das ist etwas heiß macht jetzt erstmal
mit so einer palette könnte auch ein
messer nehme oder irgendwas
was mir gerade eingefallen ich könnte
auch diesen winter nehmen mit dem kern
nämlich ganz gut diese flächen flach
drücken und versucht es so eben wie
möglich hinzubekommen
die meiste arbeit habt ihr jetzt schon
gemacht das gebe ich jetzt in den
gefrierschrank geht's einfach in den
ferien schrank haben jetzt schnell
erklärt ihr könnt es jetzt entweder in
den kühlschrank geben für etwa fünf bis
sechs stunden oder ihr geht es einfach
in den gefrierschrank für etwa zwei bis
drei stunden bis es eben richtig schön
kalt ist und dann können das weiter
benutzen und damit zeit ganz schnell
geht habe ich schon eins vorbereitet ich
hatte dass nämlich im gefrierschrank und
aus der form lässt sich das dann so ganz
einfach heraus ländern und jetzt nehme
ich das einfach und drews einmal um dann
habe ich nämlich komplett
die glatte seite hier seht ihr hier war
ein bisschen folie das macht aber nix
und jetzt richtig schön fest von der
konsistenz und ich werde hier erstmal
halbieren das könnt ihr euch natürlich
auch ganz genau abmessen
ich möchte etwas kleinere bounty regel
mache ich habe etwas schräg geschnitten
macht jetzt aber nichts
und falls ihr euch wundert was dieser
fläche ist und zwar hat dabei neben für
mich gekocht und hatte als diese
holzplatte auf dem herd und hatte herz
an gemacht und irgendwann als es dann
verbrannt hat merkt noch bevor die
flammen kamen aus denen habe ich jetzt
ein brandfleck diese kokos stücke werden
jetzt mit kuvertüre überzogen und ich
habe jetzt vorrang habe diese schon
klein gehackt und werden wir jetzt etwas
wasser kochen uns die kuvertüre
temporären und wie ich das mache zeige
ich euch ich habe jetzt hier mein frisch
abgekochtes wasser und nehme hier meine
gehackte schokolade und gibt da es
feiert zwei drittel davon in eine kleine
schüssel ein drittel stelle ich zur
seite und las jetzt hier über dem wasser
die zwei drittel schokolade schmelzen
und wenn die schokolade dann geschmolzen
ist neben dir die volle wasserbad runter
und gibt das restliche drittel dazu
jetzt wie die schokolade nämlich wieder
abgekühlt
denn kuvertüre darf nie zu heiß
verwendet werden
ansonsten bekommen sie so einen
grauschleier und das wollen wir wollen
richtig schönes glänzende schokolade und
dafür muss sie eben temperiert werden
diese methode methode und diese stoffe
den hausgebrauch ganz üblich alternativ
dazu werde das ihr euch ein temperierte
rekord aber ich hab es ist ja auch immer
so gemacht und das reicht auf jeden fall
schon wenn es dann auch komplett
aufgelöst ist und die schokolade so eine
richtig schöne konsistenz hat also schön
flüssig dann ist die schokolade gut ich
habe ziehe meine temperierte schokolade
und nehmen so einen kurs balken
wir sollten wirklich noch ganz kalt sein
also eigentlich frisch aus dem
gefrierfach ist es am besten punkt denn
hier kurz ein mit der unterseite dass
die unterseite bedeckt ist geht es dann
auf eine gabel und jetzt kann ich da
großzügig und schnell die schokolade
darüber laufen lassen
dann natürlich auch abklopfen damit er
nicht so viel schokolade drauf kommt
dann nehmt ihr euch am besten
der zweite kabel zur hilfe und setzt das
ganze auf dem backpapier damit es da
schön auskühlen kann wenn eure baum
teams richtig perfekt aussehen soll gebe
ich euch den tipp wirklich etwas pany
mit so schokolade zu geben dann wird die
schokolade richtig schön dünnflüssig und
hat auch nicht so dicke schicht drauf
und während sich das jetzt drin auflöst
zeige ich euch mal wie man die noch
schön bekommt und zwar wird durch das
schneiden werden diese dies etwas
bröselig daneben dass er einfach in die
hand und drückt die größe leicht an
dann habt ihr nämlich auch außen richtig
schön erkannten
im prinzip könnte die band ist auch
statt sie in so teil zu schneiden auch
ausstechen mit herz stand sein oder mit
anderen ausstellern
mit seht ihr hier den vergleich zu den
anderen das ist es was ich schön geformt
und abgeklopft habe und es sind die die
ich nicht richtig ganz abgeklopft habe
also das macht schon deutlichen
unterschied aus dem die regel jetzt bei
mir aus ich habe jetzt nicht alle
gemacht sondern nur etwa die hälfte
und hier habe ich noch drei mit
zartbitterschokolade überzogen weil ich
ja gerne zartbitterschokolade esse und
die gebe ich jetzt so in den kühlschrank
damit ich das backpapier transportieren
kann nehme ich mir einfach meine kuchen
unterlage meinen torten retter und gibt
es darunter und kann das jetzt so schön
in den kühlschrank stellen
ich hatte die bounty sie etwa noch mal
eine halbe stunde im kühlschrank
jetzt sind sie endlich mal und wenn sie
euch so zu langweilig sind nimmt da
einfach noch etwas schokolade
ich habe ihr gesagt sagt peter genommen
und hier vollmilch jetzt würde ich hier
zartbitterschokolade nehmen und dann
könnte die hier so drüber laufen lassen
ihr könnt aber auch ausschreiben für
eure oder euren liebsten lieb und dann
hebt ihr sie hier einfach mit einer
palette oder mit einem messer eben
man könnte hier noch diese unebenheiten
weg nehmen und hier zeige ich euch eins
und wer diesmal aufschneiden
und so sehen sie jetzt im innern aus
original wie bauen tief und jetzt wollen
wir die bauern ist natürlich noch
probieren probieren wie die original
besser die schmecken viel besser als das
original
das rezept ist wirklich empfehlenswert
und ich mag sie natürlich ganz besonders
mit der zeit wird schokolade und ich
habe wirklich nur sachen drin dieser
haben möchte ich habe meine wenigen
zutaten da drin und keine zusatzmitteln
keine emulgatoren und die bauen sie sind
wirklich sehr schnell gemacht das
einzige was eben lang dauert ist diese
wartezeit im kühlschrank bzw in der
kühltruhe die restlichen baum thiess
werde ich jetzt einfach einfrieren
und wenn ich mal wieder musste aufbauend
ist werde ich mir die sticks rausholen
mit schokolade überziehen und dann
einfach verzehren
der einzige nachteil ist nämlich dass
die jetzt nicht mehr haltbar sind
ich würde mal sagen so etwa drei bis
vier tage aber nicht länger was aber gar
nicht schlimm ist weil ihr wie gesagt
das einfach ins gefrierfach stellen
könnt ohne schokolade und daneben
auftauen
ihr könnt auch gerne mal probieren mit
schokolade einzufrieren aber ich finde
es bekommt das einkaufsmeile beim
auftauen auf jeden fall wünschen wir
euch ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen die
samira klöstern und das und gibt es
natürlich auch meinen blog auf www punkt
selbst orten wird und dann wünschen wir
euch einen ganz schnellen tag und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wie
nein kein schuss